you're looking at Minneapolis this
morning the high price of insulin there
and across the country forcing some
families with type 1 diabetes to travel
outside the US for the life-saving drug
last week and about a dozen people took
a bus 800 in 17 miles think about that
from Minneapolis to London Ontario to
buy insulin from 2012 to 2016 the price
of insulin nearly doubled in the US
Mireya Villarreal met the group in
Canada the group's day long drive
started in Minneapolis where they
boarded a bus to Canada in search of
affordable insulin do you guys put in
order on Friday
Deb Saylor has lived with type 1
diabetes for 46 years for us insulin is
like air it's like oxygen we needed Deb
says she uses three vials of insulin a
month and even with insurance she's
paying more than $700 for medicine she
can't live without it is very very
worrisome even with insurance if you
only have one vial or two vials sitting
in your refrigerator you start to stress
you do it's very stressful
so a lot of people on this bus are from
Minnesota and they traveled about 800
miles to get here but for them it's not
about the miles it's about the message
that's why they drove all the way to
London Ontario where insulin was
developed nearly a century ago getting
diagnosed today in 2019 in America with
type 1 diabetes it is a death sentence
for some people
Quinn Nystrom coordinated the trip it's
the second caravan to Canada in two
months this is a three month stock this
vial in the United States is three
hundred and forty dollars this vial
today $30.00 it's just because you
bought it in Canada it's because I
bought in Canada that's the only
difference
insulin is cheaper in Canada primarily
because the country has public health
care so the government negotiates
pricing with drug companies and caps
prices in the United States drug makers
negotiate individually with private
insurance companies and the uninsured
pay list price about seven and a half
million Americans rely on insulin to
stay alive the drug is largely supplied
by
three companies who all offer patient
assistance programs in a statement novo
nordisk told CBS News we recognize that
our health care system is broken
the added we no more must be done to
ensure insulin affordability and we are
committed to being part of the solution
but some states are taking their own
steps to lower the cost Florida passed a
law that would allow large batches of
drugs to be legally imported from Canada
into the state and colorado capped
insulin costs at $100 per monthly supply
is this a Democrat Republican situation
there's Republicans who are diabetics
there's Democrats who are diabetics and
all of us struggle to afford insulin to
me this is a human rights issue Nystrom
says she's lucky to be able to make the
trip
many people couldn't afford to miss work
coming to Canada is not a long-term
solution coming to Canada is putting a
bandaid on a gunshot wound for CBS this
morning midday of young London Ontario
Canada that price differential is insane
you see why they make a trip like
quitting Nystrom I like her voice that
little raspy voice I like that but she
says it's really about getting the
message across well they're doing a good
job of it they sure are we're looking at
about a major drug company say we
recognize our healthcare system is
broken broken you know